gentlemen
proudly welcome to the Hollywood Walk of
Fame iced tea
[Applause]
we're standing on your star on the Walk
of Fame I can't believe it how do you
describe it I can't believe it you know
where I actually came from and what I've
been through the theory of being on the
Walk of Fame is unimaginable so you know
as far as making music and all that kind
of stuff and when they told me I was
going to get one I was like nah because
I've always been an outlaw I've always
been that guy that was you know in
another Lane of hip-hop but then like we
got to the Grammys they represent us in
the Grammys and I had my birthday it's
been a hell of a week for me so I'm very
happy and excited and I realize that I'm
not only getting this start from me I'm
getting it from all my fans and people
that have supported me all these years
they're happy you know because they've
been bragging on me so now now I've been
pulled up with a star you dig it's kind
of cold right there you know what I'm
saying one of my favorite findings today
is that Mariska gets to call you icy
because you let me call you nicknames oh
no no no
that no one else is allowed to call them
you actually say it
he lets me call him I see
I told him be careful with that but she
put me on blast here but you know I love
Mariska and mariska's become a close
friend like I say how many friends have
you had for 25 years that you see every
day you know so of course we became
close and we understand we have a job to
do and we've made a show that's been on
longer than any other show so we're
friends on and off obviously wouldn't
you be a good thing and also Coco and
Chanel being here she is going to be
getting a star someday I love the fact
they just said Chanel's name and she
decided it was time to come on Save I
also want to make sure to introduce
another VIP supporting iced tea here too
Chanel
[Applause]
she heard her name she thought she
floated come on stage
when we say her name she just pulls up
how do you feel about her being in
Showbiz you know I mean you gotta back
show business with something else so she
also wants to be a doctor she you know
so I'm gonna tell her be a plastic
surgeon that ain't going out of business
but you know you gotta back this because
this is a dream
and when you base everything on a dream
a lot of times it's also called The
Boulevard of Broken Dreams so I want to
make sure she knows that you know if
that happens cool but have have
something to fall back on obviously
[Music]
thank you